pourquoi
alors qu'il les herbes et de bornes
vient d'être élue première ministre du
gouvernement pour son second mandat
d'emmanuel macro je voudrais dédier
cette nomination à toutes les petites
filles en leur disant aller au bout de
vos rêves le remaniement approche à
grands pas qui va succéder à olivier
ferrand jean michel blanquer ou roselyne
bachelot telle est la question faut il
garder ma place au chaud parce que à
balad plusieurs ministres devraient être
éconduit rassurez-vous leurs avantages
restent nombreux protection policière
indemnités certaines de ces mesures
peuvent parfois se révéler très onéreuse
s'ils ont plus aucune fonction je vois
pas pourquoi ils ont le droit d'avoir un
chauffeur l'ancien premier ministre y
bénéficient d'un secrétaire particulier
pendant dix ans et d'un véhicule avec
chauffeur n'avait pas assez mais les
aller retour en jet privé ne rentreront
pas dans les avantages alors selon vous
les ministres sortants ont-ils trop
davantage
alors oui non les ministres sortants
filtro davantage alors c'est alors c'est
un sujet c'est un peu c'est un sujet
récurrent à chaque fin de gouvernement
non pas oui mais ça a changé alors allez
vas-y ça a beaucoup changé depuis
l'époque de cahuzac effectivement à
l'époque c'était avis le secrétariat la
voiture de jour le ministre la
protection le premier cigare de ça le
prix ministre de la france et il ya les
protections toujours pour les ministres
de l'intérieur et de la justice parce
que ce sont quatre accusés sensible
c'est sûr c'est sur dix la discrétion du
ministre d'intérieur en place de laisser
ou non une protection pour les ministres
sortants si je me permets là mais c'est
vrai mais c'est en général ça ça
concerne la justice parce qu'ils ont à
l'intérieur ils ont été aussi sensible
et l'intérieur en revanche tous les
autres ministres et ce matin j'ai appelé
deux ministres peux vous dire que rien
ou alou rien du tout ils ont mûri nature
plus rien non mille secrétariat le
salaire pendant trois mois deux
ministres le salaire pendant trois
dossiers on a un petit on est un peu
c'est vrai trois mois de rumeurs on a un
petit air de trois mois c'est senna
n'était deux nations
c'est normal tu gagnes si on voit la
voiture de fonction et chauffeur sans
état sont durs et voilà c'est toujours
pareil secrétaire particulier pendant
dix ans avant c'était à vie trois mois
ouais après six mois en 2013 est certes
un peu baissé protection et ça c'est la
discrétion du ministre de l'intérieur en
place donc le secrétariat vie c'est le
changement il est assez récent il a il à
peine trois ans mais faut savoir par
exemple qu'une première ministre comme
edith cresson qui a été lu il ya 30 ans
premier ministre pendant 10 mois sous
mitterrand est là encore c'est que son
secrétariat et ça coûte beaucoup
[Musique]
d'amis maxime c'est ça la faisait sa vie
pendant dix mois non cet avis oui et ça
coûte environ entre 200000 et 400000
euros par an aux consignes justement
cette première ministre allemand on se
demande souvent vont tous les impôts et
toutes les taxes qu'on paye pas dans des
choses un final ça hexaconso à la
rigueur qu'un président de la république
bénéficie d'un traitement de faveur
parce qu'il a une autorité particulière
et problème denizli au bon rythme et je
suis désolé mais la ministre on les voit
ils peuvent je pense qu'ils peuvent
voyager tout seul devant les ministres
n'ont aucun avantage après une vaine une
fois qu'ils sont de gaza ce qui
bénéficie d'une protection armée
dépendance vis à vis des trois policiers
cécile euros par an les barreaux d'ici
là c'est une non c'est non non non ça
vous dit une bêtise le bruit de
l'intérieur en place décide ou non de
protéger un bleu hamamélis sortant ces
tickets de taubira et il s'est effondré
pendant six mois et 1000 euros mais
d'accord mais bon on va pas avant on va
pas laisser à ministre alors à la
justice de faire toutes les femmes qu'il
matin partent et qui risquent leur vie
va sans le ministre mais surtout c'est
pas justifiées on a un président qui
voit qu'il est extrêmement reconnu un
ancien premier ministre je pense qu'il
peut se déplacer tout seul qu'il n'a pas
besoin d'un secrétaire particulier
pendant dix ans ça coûte de l'argent et
encore le signal c'est désastreux je
suis désolé il a totalement raison gay
moi je suis totalement d'accord alors
évidemment quand on a été ministre de la
justice comme vous le disiez à l'instant
y'a pas de soucis mais pourquoi on peut
avec l'argent qu'ils gagnent parce
qu'après ils ne sont pas au smic les
gars d'accord ils peuvent pas se payer
un service privé de de permettre de deux
chercheurs et de vérifier notre service
privé et alors mais je sais comment ça
marche et combien ça coûte à l'état et
chez contenir ce comédien c'est le pays
parce que je garantis qu'ils peuvent ils
peuvent ainsi jean les moyens de se le
payer ma galerie sont au mieux le
patrimoine hussein pays quinze ou vingt
mille ou 30 milo mais pas c'est quand
même cher et après mais des patrimoines
est bien qu'ils investissent pour ce
pour protéger et il leur manque encore
des ministres c'est l'effet
ses avances à sa veut pas forcément dire
que la personne vient d'une famille
genre hyper ezequel un patrimoine de
dengue et c'est ça veut rien dire du
lingsar est bon mais où les idées que
les riches t ce site est ce là que
réside la plupart en tout cas il est je
les ai pas vues des îles avec les villes
et les gilets jaunes ans et je pense
qu'ils gagnent on méritait il cite pas
mais surtout il faut en fait c'est trop
facile c'est vraiment c'était plus
facile du tout de dire ça moi je suis
enfin je sais qu'il ya des ministres par
exemple là quand ils quittent leur
fonction ils savent pas là par exemple
ça fait dix jours ils savent pas encore
est ce qu'ils sont reconduits pas
reconduit ils savent pas ils auront 48
heures pour quitter leur logement de
fonction c'est qu'elle a heavy il
s'imposerait magal et on sent que magali
venait
aurait demandé à bernard était de dire
que tous ces cadeaux quoi s'est pas
rendu compte
à paramètres d'ailleurs que nous nous
connaissons ici quand on s'exprime à la
télévision et qu'on prend des décisions
et convaincants qu'on dit oui ou non sur
certaines affaires n 5 quand on est
ministre on est confronté à des idées à
des dossiers très sensibles et
effectivement parfois une protection est
bien nécessaire parce que vous êtes vous
retournez dans la vie normale commune là
vous pouvez il peut vous arriver de
salsa juste c'est pas la peine de mort
heureusement qu'il a eu pendant des
années protection où on n'est pas
content de moi que je dois m'excuser
mois mais les ailes et des policiers par
exemple qui est dans les dents des dans
des endroits peu sensibles qui sont
élevés leur tête est pratiquement mise à
prix tout ça ils n'ont pas une
protection policière est clair su désolé
ils savent en signant
ministre dépose minimes sont protégés
c'est normal vu tous les dossiers qu'ils
ont mystérieux tous les autres ministres
n'ont droit à rien du tout faut quand
même le dire ils sont virés on leur dit
merci beaucoup comme ça arrive
aujourd'hui j'ai fait venir voir et
celle ci ne donne rien oui mais là vous
focaliser sur la sécurité moi à titre
personnel ça me choque pas ce qui me
choque c'est le secrétariat le chauffeur
etc tous les gens hormis l'argent les
ministres vous dis on va pas pleurer
pour eux ce sont des gens qui ont
profité d'un réseau extraordinaire
pendant le temps où ils sont ministres
il ya du pantouflage on l'a vu récemment
avec jean baptiste djebbari qui m'aiment
pas encore partie de son poste de
ministre a déjà trouvé un poste dans le
privé c'est franchement c'est scandaleux
ces gens ne sont pas à plaindre non plus
ils ont un travail est sérieux
[Applaudissements]